[Musique]
au moment des mariages parfois dans la
salle des mariages
dans l'hôtel de ville sur la place de
l'hôtel de ville brandissent des
drapeaux étrangers ou manifeste par des
danses des des spectacles les traditions
qui sont les leurs je vois la société
sur racialisée progressivement notre
phrase du jour est signée emmanuel
macron dans une longue interview
accordée à nos confrères du journal elle
et se dit inquiet de la logique
intersectionnelle qui fracturent tout et
renvoie chacun à son identité
ça suscite énormément des mois dans la
population
sahin supporte les gens
cette manoeuvre évidemment qui est
destiné d'une part à inventer un clivage
qui n'existe pas et de l'autre côté à
nous embrouiller tous dans des
explications dont je conviens qu'elles
ne sont pas très facile à suivre
c'est quelque chose qui de sa part
exprime une forme de cynisme le pire de
l'électoralisme
je suis totalement d'accord avec sept
députés aient l'air je pense au moins
dans l'espace municipal
on est tenu à une forme de neutralité on
n'est pas chez soi
donc on n'arrive pas avec son avec son
folklore avec c'est en tout cas je vois
plus que le sirtaki y la vache
autrichienne la sardane catalan le
flamenco espagnol la salsa cubaine et le
surfeur français moi madame la députée
quand je vois des gens dont c'est
sûrement heureux filles se fout du monde
on parle pas de ça on parle des gens qui
avaient des drapeaux du maghreb dans les
mairies qui font du yoyo qui choque tout
le monde
et à qui je vais dire moi
personnellement allier où vous me ranger
ça tout ça ou je vous marie porte c'est
la république c'est ma mairie et on
respecte pour nous c'est anne hidalgo le
nom de la tribune publiée dans la presse
quotidienne régionale
elle est signée par plus de 200 élus
elle vise à promouvoir la candidature de
la maire de paris à la présidentielle je
suis dans une phase où je travaille je
pense que une décision de candidature
à l'élection présidentielle n'est pas
une décision que l'on peut prendre à la
légère au tour de l'espoir pour le monde
du tourisme avec l'entrée en vigueur du
pass sanitaire européen à partir
d'aujourd'hui ce précieux sésame qui
contient un qr code a flashé est
indispensable pour franchir des
frontières européennes
il faut poser la question d'une
obligation vaccinale en particulier nous
disons sur les classes d'âge
intermédiaire parce que nous constatons
dans les données qui nous ont été
transmises que nous publions est ce que
ça pourrait cette obligation intervenir
plus tôt oui je pense que sur le
calendrier est absolument rien de figé
je pense que tout est possible
l'obligation vaccinale c'est un outil
parmi d'autres s'il permet de gagner
quelques points de vaccination
ces quelques points peut faire la
différence pour atteindre immunité
collective et éviter à la rentrée ce
dont personne ne veut un nouveau
couvre-feu jeudi à eric le seul qui se
réjouit d'une candidature zemmour c'est
emmanuel macron parce que ça va venir
diviser le camp national je lui dis fais
attention fais attention
c'est peut-être une énorme connerie pour
vous l'avez eue au téléphone ce sont
bien des éléphants qui se baignent dans
cette piscine du zoo de portland
la scène est un symbole d'une nature qui
tente par tous les moyens de survivre
sous la chaleur accablante
la canicule a entraîné depuis vendredi
dernier près de 500 morts subites en
colombie-britannique des
hospitalisations en hausse et une
multiplication des feux de forêt fils
cosby 83 ans a été libéré après deux ans
de prison
il avait été condamné en septembre 2018
pour agression sexuelle
il avait été l'un des premiers
d'ailleurs condamné dans la foulée du
mouvement mis tout ça à peine a en fait
été annulés une question de procédure
partout une épaisse fumée
l'atmosphère est suffocante et le feu
avance très rapidement
c'est tout le village qui est en train
de partir en fumée partout autour de
nous ce sont des feux énorme